knock Muhammad Allah yes we so got your
heart it is something the Lydia for
academically therapist and I think I can
make you gangee
definitely people of Bhopal will be
occupying Delhi very close to the
Parliament Street and we are hoping that
Prime Minister Modi is going to wake up
and listen to us for what we have been
trying to say for the last 30 years that
people in Bhopal need adequate
compensation from Union Carbide and Dow
Chemical because more people from Bhopal
go to Delhi to show that after 30 years
they have not given up their fight for
justice and for adequate compensation
and there are more people in other
trains were supposed to come so we we
have to take as many as we can
whatever we have the water in the 30
years the only way to go forward is to
fight this and whatever we have gotten
whatever little compensation medical
care rehabilitation people have gotten
is because of the constant fight of the
people of a buck but shouldn't have
taken this long but we are hoping that
this 30th anniversary will also work as
you know a leverage in you know waking
up our politicians and shaming the
corporation into doing what is the right
thing for the people of Bhopal
in Bhopal India tonight another horror
story continues the Union Carbide gladly
stands silent like a tombstone in 1984 a
gas leak from a Union Carbide
corporation behind negligence suit
against Issus village worst industrial
accident the aftermath of that poison
gas killed up to 25,000 people
kind of a yeah I mean I'm a me yeah I'm
good
Malloy were drafted mess code building
full of new by the rajo-guna semester he
returns learners bizarre phone ringing
up 5k novelty was the guest with us a
while
oh maybe system on town Kibaki Monica
here sorry
the Pawnee Police Cuyuna car better than
the Pawnee inaudible you jail afonya
Tigana digital amitabha you money the
baby I am the one who comes on coloring
itself on me I'll do this myself
it's okay see ya on a nice sunny get
town or not
how do paneer is mckagan money you see
money that one again you know what come
on be given eight year with charter you
cancer are you talk - after certificates
validates a cryptic clue but you boo
what's up and we want you broke the
polymerization our I mainly Medusa
Revati
by a morality
gasps
Baljit Iowa versus of you know modular
Jay Gatsby
you see for yourself about 50 women
among these women are five survivors
women survivors of the disaster all of
whom will begin this path at this moment
women of Bhopal who bore the brunt of
the disaster from very conservative
families came out on the streets to
fight became the breadwinners became the
matriarch they are the ones who inspire
me
well we have not heard anything from the
Modi government from the last three
months that we have been trying to
communicate with him and now that people
are on the fast without water things get
really crazy and scary for people who
are doing this we are just hoping that
they will fix the wrong that has been
been done in Baba
so the delegation of the representatives
of your waffle accident met the Minister
and Minister Dave now discussed with all
the representatives and he has agreed
further condition you come right to
Kovac
this means we have no reason to believe
by he will go back on it what he has
said but we will beyond on this gauge
and on the minister's case until the
figures are reaches justice and boppin
is very important but justice and poeple
also means that we can set a precedent
right we can tell the world that
marginalized people are not dispensable
that corporations cannot get away with
murder that profit maximization cannot
be put before people's health in lives